bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mac
la sécurité reste la préoccupation
majeure des français
ce mois ci nous nous sommes rendus dans
les commissariat d'elancourt et de
trappes délinquance du secteur et police
scientifique nous ferons le point
nous parlerons prévention et politique
de la ville avec la vice présidente de
l'agglomération suzanne blanc prévention
et aide aux victimes le quotidien de
l'association dire où nous sommes allés
pour toute question juridique ça se
passe à la maison de la justice et du
droit
enfin nous évoquerons le futur
commissariat d'agglomération avec jean
michel fourgous président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la sécurité du
territoire ont fait le point c'est parti
[Musique]
la sécurité c'est le plus important
c'est primordial on n'est plus aussi
confiant qu'avant c'est un mystère qui
méritent en effet amplement ses besoins
on est malheureusement dans une période
où où il ya des agressions de tout le
monde à part tout le monde donc on sait
plus du tout comment faire pour
retrouver la paire la délinquance
juvénile
il ya des adolescents qui agresse qui
font déviation d'homicide qui se
droguent et je vous avoue que le soir je
sors plus tout seul alors qu'avant nos
parents nous laissait vraiment jouer
dehors sans problème et aujourd'hui on
n'a plus cette sensation de sécurité
donc j'espère que les élus d'ici
omettront permettront aussi à l'ordre du
jour donné les moyens en fait à la
sécurité et pour sécuriser les citoyens
la sécurité des biens et des personnes
préoccupation majeure des français les
plus de 65 ans ils sont les plus
sensibles ainsi que les habitants des
grandes villes et des banlieues
défavorisées
un thème qui devance de peu la
préoccupation environnementale et le
développement économique
nous sommes confrontés sur la
circonscription de sécurité publique des
longs cours à des problématiques de
délinquance variés qu'il s'agisse de
cambriolages d'atteintes aux biens c'est
à dire de vols de véhicules de vols à la
roulotte de dégradation nous sommes
également être amené à travailler sur
des trafics et usage et revente de
produits stupéfiants sur les différentes
communes qui composent notre
circonscription
toutes nos unités de voie publique sont
d'une part mobilisé
qu'il s'agisse des brigades de roulement
de nos gsp de nos groupe de sécurité de
proximité qui sécurise qui procèdent à
des interpellations
et puis également nous avons mis en
place donc un dispositif particulier sur
le quartier de reconquête républicaine
de trappes qui est qui a été créée en
printemps 2018
nous avons également donc le concours
bien évidemment du service
d'investigation dans ce dispositif au
sein de ce dispositif donc la sûreté
urbaine de trappes est également
mobilisée avec les différents groupes d'
enquête et avec la base technique qui
apporte une aide considérable et qui
permet l'identification de nombreuses
auteurs d'infractions nous avons l'une
des bases techniques les plus
performantes d'île de france
[Musique]
ok les deux en même temps au plus serré
par la base technique est installé au
sein de la sûreté urbaine de trappes
neuf policiers la composent dont un
spécialiste en police technique et
scientifique
ces derniers interviennent sur les
scènes d'infraction relevés de traces
d'un 10 et constatations sont effectués
afin de confondre les auteurs une unité
qui permet un taux important
d'élucidation vingt-et-une personnes
sont identifiées chaque mois cent trente
trois individus ont été identifiées
grâce au relevé d'empreintes génétiques
depuis début 2010 9
trente et une autres grâce aux relevés
de traces papillaires transmise au faed
ainsi le taux d'élucidation des
cambriolages a progressé de 11% depuis
le début de l'année 2019 niveau on
utilise des poudres donc qui nous
permettent de relever les
les empreintes et également on utilise
des échos ayant pour rechercher tous
qu'il trace adn mais ce coup lyon où on
peut écarter des objets également après
il ya d'autres services où tu nous que
lors que ça de même un peu plus
importante qui interviennent à l'aide de
procédés physico-chimiques donc on peut
écarter également des objets pour faire
des procédés physico chimiques qui
seront faits un laboratoire
ce matin là les policiers de la base
technique sont intervenus sur les lieux
d'un cambriolage
c'est un morceau de portes que j'ai
prélevé à l'extérieur qui leur a fait
faire les individus qui ont jeté dans le
jardin et qui n'a pas été manipulée par
la victime
donc c'est pour ça que je les privés
dans ce flacon a été prélevé un adn ces
relevés seront transmis au laboratoire
afin d'effectuer toutes les recherches
physico chimiques permettant
d'identifier le ou les auteurs autres
indices prélevés ce matin là sur un
miroir une trace papillaire justement
relevé les empreintes de la victime pour
comparaison pour discriminer les
victimes en cas de cambriolage de vols à
la roulotte
surtout ne rien toucher même avec des
gants mais appeler le 17
revenu des lieux de l'infraction le
policier va établir son rapport afin de
décrire les circonstances de
cambriolages sur le logiciel crimine la
scène du crime comportant un plan des
lieux les photos et les prélèvements
sera reproduite et dématérialisés
valenciennes dont il fut beaucoup de
personnes a précédé service enquêteur
qui permettent de
de faire la vérité sur ce qu'on retrouve
même sur ce travail des kills de son
côté le commissariat de guyancourt
oeuvre contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes
depuis novembre dernier les locaux
héberge le portail nationale de
signalement contre ces infractions
celui ci permet un échange 7 jours sur 7
et 24 heures sur 24 avec un policier ou
une psychologue pour toujours plus
d'écouté et d'accompagnement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines compte douze
services de police municipale une
brigade de gendarmerie
onze villes équipées d'un système de
vidéoprotection afin d'éviter la case
commissariat mieux vaut prévenir la
communauté d'agglomération travail la
prévention avec les partenaires du
territoire prévention et accompagnement
des victimes ont fait le point
la politique de la ville une compétence
obligatoire des communautés
d'agglomération le contrat de ville
intercommunal de saint quentin en
yvelines a été signé en 2015 pour une
durée de cinq ans il impulse un soutien
au public des quartiers prioritaires ou
en veille active décrochage scolaire
prévention de la délinquance laïcité en
2017 deux axes ont été rajoutés
l'égalité femmes hommes et la prévention
contre la radicalisation en 2019
l'agglomération a attribué un million et
demi d'euros de subventions à une
trentaine d'associations et partenaires
de la politique de la ville et chaque
association a sa méthode avec le centre
athéna
c'est plus via les apprendre aux élèves
collégiens lycéens leur apprendre
comment détecter défectueuses par
exemple avec rapide blog les médias mais
les média magazines journaux etc que
l'on sélectionné comment savoir qui
parle de courant quelles sont les
tendances politiques même de certains
magazines
on a également des kits théâtre qui
intervient et c'est bien évidemment soin
soit les jeux de rôle mais au delà
et puis marmite fm sparfel interviennent
ensemble c'est pas contraignant c'est
une autre forme de pédagogie 27% de la
population des sept communes concernées
par la politique de la ville au moins de
19 ans les communes elles mêmes mène des
actions auprès des jeunes
organisation de voyages réalisation de
fresques dans les quartiers et avec la
participation des jeunes
même si évidemment on aura pas 100
jeunes à la fois et en tout cas même
s'il y en a 5 ou seul tous disent c'est
déjà bien de se dire que ces jeunes là
ils vont retrouver un équilibre social
important pour eux mêmes
[Musique]
l'association dire basé à montigny le
bretonneux est un partenaire de longue
date du territoire
elle a été créée il ya 30 ans l'objectif
c'était c'était à l'époque qui est
toujours d'ailleurs c'était d'être dans
les quartiers dits verticaux ou une
forte densité de logements dits sociaux
pour venir à la fois en aide sont des
jeunes préadolescents et adolescents et
jeunes adultes
j'ai aussi auprès des familles de
manière à monter avec des projets
individuels et collectifs pour essayer
de tracer un peu un avenir plus joyeux
pour cela des lieux d'écouté
d'orientation ont été mises en place
oman est dans le quartier des prés et à
la souris insertion éducation et emploi
voire hébergement les sujets phares de
dire le deuxième volet de dire l'aide
aux victimes
deux juristes pénaliste et trois
psychologues cliniciens interviennent au
sein des 13 lieux de permanence que
comptent dire sur saint quentin en
yvelines et le sud du département que la
punition par rapport à ces victimes
d'infractions pénales donc c'est de les
recevoir de les écouter d'analyser leur
besoin de les informer juridiquement de
les soutenir psychologiquement de les
orienter vers les partenaires
spécialisés si nécessaire et de les
accompagner la des actions spécifiques
mis en place donc au sein de
l'association dire qu'ils sont des
actions principalement à destination des
enfants
donc on a une action pour les enfants
témoins de violences conjugales
donc les psychologues reçoivent en
entretien individuel les enfants qui ont
été témoins de violences au sein du
couple parental on a des actions pour
les enfants victimes de harcèlement
scolaire
on fait des interventions en milieu
scolaire également dire et référente
pour toutes les victimes d'infractions
pénales atteintes aux personnes
violences agressions sexuelles mais
aussi les atteintes aux biens
escroquerie vol dégradations
cambriolages dire accueille aussi les
victimes d'accidents de la circulation
et de catastrophes collectives
les actes de terrorisme et catastrophes
naturelles les juristes de l'association
interviennent aussi dans les locaux de
la maison de la justice et du droit mjd
c'est un lieu d'écouté d'information
juridique ou toute personne qui estime
avoir besoin de renseignements endroits
peuvent venir sans rendez vous un
service gratuit et confidentiel droit de
la famille divorce pension alimentaire
droit du travail de la consommation ou
encore droit pénal
victime comme auteurs d'infractions
viennent s'y renseigner notamment pour
constituer un dossier dead
juridictionnelle dans ses locaux 4
juriste généraliste et une douzaine
d'intervenants
on leur offre toute la palette de ce
qu'ils peuvent faire au niveau des
procédures mais par contre on ne
conseille pas céder avocat et on
réoriente cette personne n'a vers des
avocats qui tiennent justement aussi des
permanences h et la mjd intervient dans
les collèges et les lycées
les mineurs peuvent se rendre dans ses
locaux pour compléter leurs demandes
d'information en 2018
douze mille quatre cents personnes ont
été reçues sur les deux antennes
saint-quentinoise vous voici à l'hôtel
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en présence de
son président jean michel fourgous
bonjour bonjour donc on l'a vu avec les
micro trottoirs avec les études récentes
la sécurité demeure la priorité des
français c'est aussi une priorité de la
communauté d'agglomération oui la
première la violence je pense c'est la
première injustice pour les français
elle étend en hausse
il faut arrêter de le nier faut arrêter
déni que l'on a de beaucoup de politique
donc à 50 animations on s'approprie ce
problème très directement alors il faut
dire que grâce aux jeux olympiques grâce
au fait que 50 a été choisi après la
ryder cup sic a été tout un succès on
nous a confié quatre sites olympiques
organisés et dans ce cadre là ça nous
allait le moteur pour pouvoir obtenir
l'attribution de
du duduk d'un commissariat
d'agglomération de nouvelle génération
donc on sera le premier com et sa
nouvelle génération ça fait dix ans
qu'on a vu donc là on a eu enfin
l'agrément de l'état dans le cadre bien
sûr des géo donc on est enchanté de
pouvoir enfin se lancer sur ce projet et
de répondre vraiment à la première
demande de nos administrés de 50 ans
niveau d'accord alors il se situera à
elle encourt toujours oui parce qu'on a
le comice a le plus obsolète
elle encourt donc il et c'est pour ça
qu'on l'administration de la police mais
ça ne la choisit bien sûr elancourt qui
coordonnera bien sûr on garde le
commissariat de guyancourt a attrapé du
tram ça ce sera trois commissariats qui
seront hyper connectés cirque si tu
vends une nouvelle génération de façon
de travailler beaucoup plus modernes
mieux coordonnées on peut se coordonner
beaucoup plus d'acteurs que ce soit un
chef d'établissement une gare ce qui se
passe dans l'autobus dans les transports
dans tous les équipements publics police
municipale police nationale gendarmerie
tout ça pompiers la coordination sera
beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup plus
précise bien sûr avec des moyennes de 2
2 où les housses l'ensemble des acteurs
seront connectés et tu veux dire que ça
fait gagner du temps l'efficacité ça
protège beaucoup mieux nos policiers
et puis aussi pour les victimes alors il
faut trois ans attention c'est pas part
aux deux genoux problème passable pour
demain à 9 heures oui tout cela en tout
cas va dans le bon sens on est très
heureux d'enfin avoir ce projet après
dix ans
d'avoir ramené très bien merci beaucoup
mais c'est le président de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce futur commissariat
d'agglomération ski mag c'est fini à
très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]